Today.
It is my very great privilege and pleasure to introduce Andrew Goldstone,
a TF in this course.
Um,
Andrew is going to provide for you today.
The only relief you will get all term from my voice.
So enjoy it.
Um,
on the syllabus it says that I would be presenting electron censorship in this
slot.
Um,
that's been suppressed.
It's been suppressed.
That's right.
Um,
so I will talk about censorship,
um,
somewhat,
uh,
in my last lecture on the Lita and in preparation for that for next week,
I'd like you to finish the novel and then read his essay on a novel entitled
Lolita should be bound at the back of your book.
Um,
Andrew is a fourth year student in the Phd Program in English and he is writing
a dissertation on,
um,
the autonomy of the work of art and modernism on that as a problem,
on that as a,
I'm subject to be questioned and understood in a deeper way than it has been up
til now.
It's a wonderful dissertation.
Um,
it prepares them very well for the lecture he's going to give you today.
So Andrew,
thanks Amy.
So on Monday who had three main themes that we're used to introduce this
novelty.
You first is the idea that the novel invites ethical questions,
but also holds them off through parody in the same way that it uses the tropes
of Romanticism and romantic love and parodies them.
Secondly,
we looked at Humberto techniques of rhetorical seduction and related that to a
kind of intellectual problem that in a Boca sets himself of trying to make you
identify but this villainous character.
And that leads to the third big question we looked at,
which is the place of Novakof in this novel amidst the many layers,
whether he crosses them or confuses them.
And that that's the question that I'm mostly gonna focus on today.
I'm going to bracket the ethical question.
Leave that for Monday's lecture.
And the way I want to approach this question of the style and the novel and the
question of Aestheticism is by placing a Bokeh in the context of literary
modernism.
So I'm going to outline for you a little bit what I mean by that term.
And then I'm going to look at some specific,
uh,
predecessors that in Boca for first two and the way he uses them.
And then at the very end,
I'm going to try to connect that to an [inaudible] exile and the themes of
exile.
So let's start with an example.
Uh,
if you look on page 15,
Humbert describes his adolescence,
uh,
his education.
At first,
I plan to take a degree in psychiatry as many Monquet talents do,
but I was even more among k than that.
A peculiar exhaustion.
I'm so pressed doctor set in and I switched to English literature where so many
frustrated poets and as pipe smoking teachers in tweeds.
Well that's why I'm in graduate school.
Uh Huh.
Paris suited me.
I discussed Soviet movies with expatriates.
I sat with Uranus in the Duma ago.
I published torturous essays in obscure journals.
I compose pastiches Humberto poem,
Freud Line,
fun coop may turn her hand upon the DOR.
I will not follow her,
nor fresca nor Batgirl.
So this is a spoof of a poem by Ts Elliot,
which I've given you a piece of on your handout.
So let's look at that for a second.
Elliot's 1920 Poem Garanti Ian and Jessica to read a little bit of this so that
you have the flavor of the thing of Bokeh is burlesque game.
Here I am an old man in a dry month being read to by a boy waiting for rain.
I was neither at the hot gates nor fought in the warm rain nor knee.
Deep in the salt marsh,
heaving a cutlass bitten by flies,
fought my house is a decade house.
And the poem goes on.
And this is,
this is the tone of a poem.
It's a poem of crisis,
a poem of a kind of hollow speaker,
someone who emerges is more or less buried alive.
And this is supposed to reflect both personal crisis and the historical crisis.
Uh,
and it comes to a moment where,
uh,
the possibility of rejuvenation is described as devoured by series of,
characatures of Europeans.
And that's the second part on your handout.
The people that devour a rejuvenation,
uh,
so by Haka gala bowing among the Titians by madame to torn fist in the dark
room,
shifting the candles.
Freud line,
fun coop.
There she is.
Who turned in the hall one hand on the door.
They can shuttles.
We've the wind.
I have no ghosts and old man in the drafty house under a windy knob.
What in Elliot is crisis in Boca.
F is just a joke.
In other words,
these terrifying figures in Elliot Freud line phone call are just some of
Humberto name phets Freud lines,
just a young woman fresca another Elliot character,
the fresh woman,
right?
A young woman again,
so I called this a burlesque of Elliot's modernism.
It takes something meant to be really serious and turns it into a dirty joke and
that's the first way in Boca for will relate to literary modernism.
That's quite interesting that he takes this approach because Elliot in some ways
comes very close to the kind of ideas about art that in a book of himself holds.
Elliot says poems should be autotelic.
That means they should be an end unto themselves and in Boca full say in that
afterwards you're going to read the novel has only purpose to afford aesthetic
bliss.
So the parodies of something very close to home,
and this poem that I've given you will come comeback,
uh,
on page one 34.
You don't have to turn to that now,
but you should think about that return.
It's much more serious and strange.
Okay,
so that's enough on Elliot.
Now I want to really clarify for you what I mean by this term.
Modernism.
It just means the art,
uh,
and literature of the early 20th century,
especially the high art,
although its roots are definitely in the 19th century,
especially the French 19th century fiction and poetry in English.
It begins with the late novels of Henry James Around 1900 and poetry with Elliot
and with Ezra pound,
uh,
in,
in prose.
It's main exemplars in English would be James Joyce,
Virginia Woolf,
and you should know about this movement that it had very rapid success.
So although it's first centers or London and Paris,
it's already taught as classic literature in American universities before the
war,
they already classic.
So now here's a,
I'm just a list for you.
Eight features of literary modernism that are all important to in a Boca eight
features of literary modernism and obsession with the idea of arts autonomy.
The idea that art is its own law,
that it responds to no other laws,
that it has no other purpose than its own purposes.
In other words,
art for Art's sake,
that's Elliot's autotelic poem.
The only purpose of the work of artists who afford aesthetic bliss.
Second,
a sense of crisis,
a radical break in culture and overturning of conventional artistic forms that
goes with a sense that civilized civilization itself is being overturned.
Third,
the idea that the paradigm of experience is artistic experience.
That the norms for everyone should be artistic norms of careful perception.
Uh,
deep reflection that the idea that culture itself is the saving most important
activity that people can engage in.
Fourth,
and this goes along with that.
A rejection of convention,
especially sexual conventions,
sexual morality,
that's obvious connection to this book,
the very deep roots of modernism.
However,
at the same time,
there's an idea that the artist is a kind of technician,
someone whose values are craft,
form and style rather than message,
personal expression of wisdom of any kind.
Six.
Uh,
this is a term from the critic,
Josef Frank spacial form,
spatial form.
The idea that in place of a linear narrative,
you have a system of cross references and repeated motifs that give the
structure of works in place that is only visible,
in other words,
on rereading,
only visible on rereading.
And then this is anticipates my last points.
Modernism is self consciously international.
Uh,
in other words,
it will look to international tradition and it has as its ambition to be a
culture and not just for one nation,
but for many,
maybe for all,
uh,
going along with this eighth characteristic that's important.
The artist is seen as a kind of spiritual exile.
Someone who is alienated from a home society and home culture,
whether or not he or she is actually left it as [inaudible] did.
So this is what I mean by international high modernism.
Uh,
you should add to this list of writers,
especially Faulkner.
And Hemingway,
and you should remember that there's a parallel American tradition.
Uh,
the realist tradition that we saw Richard Wright referring to that is Theodore
Dreiser Sinclair Lewis.
And then going back to the 19th century writers like Mark Twain.
You know,
I had a teacher who used to compare Lolita to huck Finn.
There two novels about traveling across America in an unconventional couple,
right?
Um,
so anyway,
uh,
okay.
But now that modernist tradition is something that new book of owes a lot too,
but he always tries to distinguish himself from it.
Uh,
from the book of the highest value is originality.
He says this in his last Russian novel,
the gift,
or he doesn't say it,
his autobiographical hero says it.
Any genuinely new trend in art is a night's move,
a change of shadows,
a shift that displaces the mirror.
Okay.
Any genuinely new trend is a night's move.
So just remind you in chess,
the night doesn't move in a straight line.
It starts out in a straight line and that had hops off on the diagonal.
Unlike any other piece,
it skips over pieces in the way.
So the night far from going on the straight course surprises you,
you might think of walking in here expecting Professor Hungerford on censorship
and getting me instead.
Uh,
but this is really very important idea for an Invoca both as a way of treating
predecessors and as a way of writing.
I want to show you that way of writing,
uh,
very early in the book on page 10.
Now let's take a look at that.
Yeah,
this is at the top of the page.
My very photogenic mother died in a freak accident,
picnic lightning when I was three and save for a pocket of warmth in the darkest
past.
Nothing of hers subsists within the hollows and Dells of memory over which,
if you can still stand my style,
I'm writing under observation.
The son of my infancy had set.
Okay,
so this is a nice move from traumatic event of the mother's death.
Should be the center of the sentence is just dismissed.
Hop beyond into this stylistic wash,
a golden haze.
And he goes on to describe the sensations of early childhood.
So the strategy of the move is to frustrate your expectations.
To reap over the apparently important events into something else characterized
by a kind of aesthetic play.
And these parentheses are a real icon of that.
A critic has counted 450 sets of them in this novel.
The parenthesis,
important example of knights move.
But I want to show you another kind of nights move and to do that,
I'm going to talk just for a moment about new book us relationship to the French
writer,
Proust.
Uh,
Proust is the great aesthetic cyst of modernism,
but the novelist who writes about art,
who holds up art as a value as well as giving a theory of memory and memory is
very important in Lolita.
That really comes from perused a theory of memory that has a lot to do with the
work of the artist.
And the book of in 1966 he said this,
the greatest masterpieces of 20th century prose.
This is convenient.
Take this down,
are in this order.
Joyce's Ulysses is transformation.
That is the metamorphosis,
Belize,
St Petersburg,
a pretty obscure Russian avant garde novel.
And the first half of proofs fairy tale in search of lost time.
I mentioned of the fairytale should remind you of that first meeting between
Humbert and Lolita described that we looked at on Monday described in fairy
terms,
but actually the thing I want to think about is accrued pun there a fairytale.
Uh,
Proust is himself gay.
One of his big subjects is homosexuality.
And the book us reaction to this is really homophobic.
Uh,
this is not just about new focus,
personal prejudice.
It's about a relationship to predecessors who are seen as two similar.
The danger from the Boca.
Remember that as value as originality,
the danger is that you will fall too in love with something to like himself.
He has to hold off this possibility of being too attracted to these male
predecessors who are too similar to him.
Uh,
this should cue you to think about the theme of doubling in this novel.
To think about the possibility of desire between men here to think about the
word queer.
The treatment of guests don't go down that funny French character in Beardsley,
uh,
to think about Humberto contest.
Constant protestations that he's attractive to all women about is supposed to
virility.
Um,
and uh,
it should,
um,
just make you wonder whether pedophilia is in itself a kind of nights move from
homosexuality.
In other words,
is there another form of perverted desire hiding behind the one that's in front
of us?
Let's look on a,
just a suggestion.
Look on page 20.
Yeah.
Still in Humberto early life.
Near the bottom.
It happened,
for instance,
that from my balcony,
I would notice a lighted window across the street and what looked like an infant
in the act of undressing before a cooperative mirror,
thus isolated,
thus removed the vision acquired and especially King charm that made me race
with all speed toward my loan gratification.
So you have a kind of image there of the autonomous aesthetic pleasure,
right?
The pleasure of imagination that's taken alone according to one's own thoughts
rather than in some broader,
more social forum,
but abruptly fiendishly the tender pattern of nudity I had adored would be
transformed into the disgusting lamplight bare arm of a man in his underclothes
reading his paper by the open window in the hot damp,
hopeless summer night.
So that,
that the,
the object of this wonderful aesthetic reverie than in fat turns out to be an
adult male.
And I just want you to ask yourself why that could be,
but Nepal,
because relationship to this modernist past is not just the burlesque that he
visits on.
Elliott is not just this complicated attraction and disidentification that he
works on with Proust,
uh,
part of,
an element of admiration is also present.
Uh,
and that's,
that's really part of his relationship to Joyce.
Remember that he name's Joyce as the greatest master of 20th century prose.
Uh,
just going to name for you for features of Joyce's style that are important to
novakof stylistic virtuosity,
the ability to imitate any style at the same time,
a scrupulous attention to the banality of everyday life in all its detail.
Yet.
Third characteristic,
the constant use of a super imposed structure.
So in Ulysses famously joist puts the narrative of the Odyssey on top of a day
in Dublin or in Joyce's earlier novel,
a portrait of the artist as a young man,
a linear narrative in which a young boy grows up is structured as a series of
structurally parallel chapters in which moments in each one corresponds to the
ones in successive chapters.
And this has comes with a kind of suggestion that that been now reality is
redeemed by the art,
the artists activity.
Fourthly,
Joyce loves puns.
Sodas.
Bulk of this is incredibly important.
Uh,
and there's a direct glance at that,
uh,
just ahead of where you read.
So don't turn here.
I don't want to spoil what's coming up.
But on page two 21,
there's a reference to,
uh,
don't look,
don't look to a writer named Vivian dark bloom plagiarizing from Joyce now,
Vivian dark room.
You remember from Monday,
that's the Anagram of Vadim [inaudible].
Uh,
so an explicit recognition and the thing that's being plagiarized,
I've actually given you on the handout,
it's a little piece of Finnegans wake.
Okay.
Which is Joyce's work in which almost every word is upon almost every word is a
pun.
Just read you a sentence of this too.
So you know what it's like.
Say them all,
but tell them apart.
Cat in Zalando Coloratura artists,
we Bretta and a is a rancha.
Why is for Ula and n for green,
Erin B as boy blue with auto Liscow while w waters the florets of November,
it's that spells out rainbow,
right?
Um,
the important thing here is that in Boca Technologies,
this debt to Joyce as not just a parody but a real debt.
Uh,
and so now I want to think at more length about another joy solution,
which,
uh,
shows how complicated the relationship to his predecessor is.
Uh,
and with Elliot,
I read the,
the Nabokovian Virgin first.
This time.
I'll give you the Joyce first.
So this is on your handout as well.
From chapter two,
uh,
this describes the hero,
Stephen Dedalus,
uh,
as a young boy,
writing,
trying to write a poem.
And eventually in the novel he will succeed,
uh,
in writing a poem.
Uh,
but here he doesn't manage to.
And so this is a kind of forecast of what will happen later on.
Uh,
the further complication is that here he's writing a poem and then he remembers
an earlier attempt that layering of memory and that kind of layering is actually
a prototype for the layering in Lolita.
The next day,
this is under chapter two.
The next day he sat at his table and the bare upper room for many hours before
him lay a new pen,
a new bottle of ink,
and a new emerald exercise.
Skip a little on the first line of the page appeared the title of the verses he
was trying to write to EEC.
He knew what was right to begin.
So for you it seems similar titles in the collected poems of Lord Byron,
when he had written this title and drawn an ornamental line underneath,
he fell into a daydream and began to draw diagrams on the corner of the book.
He saw himself sitting at his table and Bray the morning after the discussion at
the Christmas dinner table trying to write a poem about Parnell on the back of
one of his father's second Boyd,
he notices but his brain then refuse to grapple with the theme.
And desisting he had covered the page with the names and addresses of certain of
his classmates,
Roderick kick him,
John Lawton,
Antony McSweeney,
Simon Moonen.
The version of this that comes up in the novel is in the midst of Humboldt's
diary.
And the diary itself,
I should say as a lot,
uh,
owes a lot to Joycean.
I've given you a piece that diary to look at,
uh,
on your own on the handout.
Uh,
but this is the moment that directly alludes to portrait and it's really very
important for understanding and focus technique.
So page 51,
near the bottom
Thursday,
we are paying with Halan Gail for the tropical beginning of the month and a
volume of the young people's encyclopedia.
I found a map of the states that a child's pencil had started copying out on a
sheet of lightweight paper upon the other side of which counter to the
unfinished outline of Florida and the Gulf.
There was a mimeographed list of names referring evidently to her class at the
Ramsdale school.
Might think of that front and back of the page as another kind of nights move
there.
You think you're looking at one thing,
you land on another.
It is a poem I know already by Heart,
Angel Grace,
Austin,
Floyd [inaudible],
Jack Biel,
Mary Buck,
Daniel and so on.
I'll come back to this list.
Actually just skip to the bottom on page 52 Talbot,
Edgar Talvin,
Edwin Wayne Lull,
lull in the book,
Right Williams Ralph when Muller Luis,
a poem,
a poem for suits.
So strange and sweet was it to discover this haze Dolores,
she and it's special bower of names with its bodyguard of roses,
a fairy princess between her two maids of honor that that's a fairy tale.
Again,
in a way,
this is just like the Joyce.
A list of names leads up to this aesthetic sensation.
The,
the revelation of a poem,
uh,
the ordinary materials of life become the basis for a kind of artistic
achievement.
However,
obviously this is not like the Joyce where there is a realistic depiction of a
young boy trying to write,
getting bored and failing here.
Something else is happening because the list of names is not ordinary,
right?
There's that bower of roses that refers to Mary Rose,
Hamilton,
Hayes,
Dolores Hanuk,
Rosaline,
and then there's Emil Rosato and car mine rose,
a red rose angel grace.
I mean really,
ah,
Stella fantasy.
Uh,
and then even the ordinary names are,
are kind of plants because almost every name on this list comes back elsewhere
in the book.
You could look,
for example,
for Louise Wind Muller,
or,
um,
Vivian McChrystal,
and then right in the middle,
oh,
and then we have Shakespeare to Miranda,
Antony,
Miranda,
viola.
Um,
and right in the middle you have a kind of explanation,
uh,
planted Macu,
Virginia McCrystal,
Vivian mcfate,
Aubrey mic FAPE,
which as you know,
is something Humbard gets kind of obsessed with is the icon of the difference
between the realistic world of Joyce and the already artificial already
aestheticize world of this novel.
No one was ever really named mcfate.
Uh,
mic fate is a kind of parody of real randomness.
You might think of it as having the same relation to real fate as chicken
mcnuggets due to chicken.
In other words,
might think of it as a kind of artificial processed,
a bland,
easily consumable version of faith.
I really mean that.
You know,
one of the funny things about that debt to Finnegan's wake is Finnegan's wake as
a book of puns is unreadable.
Nobody reads it except specialists like me.
Lalita was a best seller.
Lito was a bestseller and then broke.
I've made so much money from it.
He was able to retire to Switzerland.
And you should ask yourself,
what about this novel makes that possible?
Why is that that you have this mcnugget version of the modernist novel?
And I don't don't really mean that to disparage the novel,
but it's makes it clear that there's some kind of difference between this and
the works that Nebraska is looking back to.
I want to think a little bit more about this idea of a mic fate.
There's a kind of short circuit between,
uh,
between the Joycey and idea of taking ordinary life and transforming it into an
aesthetic order because the ordinary is already a static in the book.
In other words,
chance is already faded.
The thing that stands for randomness in this book,
the thing that looks like ordinary detail has already been arranged to give you
artistic pleasure.
Uh,
that's why Humbert,
uh,
can be instantly delighted in the list of names.
This doesn't look forward to Humberto poems.
It already is a poem,
uh,
and it is a poem to the crazed aroused mind of Humber.
So there's,
the artificial has taken the place of the real here and this novel really
reminds you of that all the time.
Uh,
on 84,
Humbert says a hundreds thinking of killing Charlotte.
And he says,
no man can bring about the perfect murder.
Chance,
however,
can do it,
chance can do it.
And of course,
the perfect murder does happen.
Uh,
Charlotte Hayes dies at as if by total accident.
But we're aware that the asset is so perfect that it was arranged.
So this is the kind of hand of Novakof taking a narrative of real events and
twisting it into something that makes a kind of sense,
taking fate and making it Mick fate.
Uh,
and I want to show you one more example of that.
uh,
in the scene where Humbert and Lolita,
I've reached the hotel,
the enchanted hunters.
This is on page one 18.
Okay.
Near the bottom in the slow,
clear hand of crime,
I wrote Doctor Edgar,
h Humbert and daughter three 42 long street.
Ramsdale a key three 42 was half shown to me.
Magician showing object.
He's about to palm and hand it over to uncle Tom.
Yeah,
the coincidence.
Normally in real life,
it would be a delightful coincidence to go to a hotel room that has the same
number as your street address.
Here.
It's a kind of too easy icon of the correspondence between the place where
Humbard meets Lolita and the place where he rapes her.
And the book just tells you that.
Right?
And one of those parentheses,
the magician showing the object is about to palm the ordinary event,
which is really trickery,
trickery as suggestion that nothing has been left to chance in the novel.
Nothing is ordinary.
Uh,
no,
it's like come to my last section here.
What I want to suggest is that this kind of transformation of arbitrary real
faded events into conspicuously artificial tricks,
which you might think of as a night's move on.
The real fete fate,
uh,
is a response in particular to exile,
in particular in invoke condition of exile
and exile living in a foreign country,
Liz,
in a kind of a d naturalized world,
a world where instead of everything making instance sense,
everything has to be decoded,
right?
Nothing is initially known to make sense.
Everything has to be figured out and reinvent it.
And that afterward to this book and the book of says he had to invent America.
He had to invent America.
That's because he didn't know it already.
It wasn't given to him.
Now,
in a way,
this is a terrible state,
a state of discontinuity with the world you exist in,
but it has a payoff kind of a pay off,
which is the possibility precisely of inventing a,
and this is,
this is visible everywhere in this book.
Uh,
one example is the transformation of housework.
this is on page one 79.
My West door neighbor West door,
who might've been a businessman or a college teacher or both would speak to me
once in a while as he barbered some late garden blooms or watered his car or at
a later date defrosted his driveway.
I don't mind if these verbs are all wrong.
Of course,
the point is that they're all wrong.
The point is that this cliched suburban life of mowing the lawn or washing the
car and so on has been transformed precisely because Humbard as a foreigner and
to something you can laugh at something,
you can joy,
something you can enjoy,
something that you can apply.
The night's move to.
Uh,
and this is even a couple of pages before explicitly described as something
particularly to foreigners because you remember,
gas don't go down,
says about the school that Lalita is going to go to.
The girls are taught not to spell very well,
but to smell very well.
Uh,
and Humbert comments.
That's where the foreigners love for such things.
Uh,
the foreigners love for this kind of move is a response to this dean naturalized
world of the exile.
Yeah.
It's important in this connection to remember that the knights move as a way of
avoiding obstacles in particular keeps skipping over,
uh,
forms of violence.
Ah,
there's that mother's death at the beginning.
Uh,
there's another moment in which Humbert is tracing his hand along the lead his
leg and he discovers a bruise there that he'd given her accidentally.
That's early on in the book.
In other words,
the surprise is a violence surprise.
Uh,
you can even look at the mention of a night's move in this book.
that's page one 92,
one of the lattice squares in a small cobwebby casement window at the turn of
the staircase was glazed with Ruby and that raw wound among the unstained
rectangles and it's asymmetrical position a nights move from the top always
extremely disturbed me.
Okay.
The Knights move,
which is just a playful way of describing where the window is,
right?
The knights move is nonetheless a kind of wound or damage.
So even as it's the prototype for originality,
it's also something very disturbing and harmful.
And that conjunction,
I want to suggest that conjunction has to do with the traumatic event of having
had to emigrate.
Uh,
having had to take up another language in the Boca will say that his private
tragedy is that,
uh,
let's see,
his private tragedy,
which cannot and indeed not be anybody's concern,
is that I had to abandon my natural idiom,
my untrammeled rich and infinitely docile Russian tongue for a second rate brand
of English,
devoid of any of those apparatuses.
The Baffling Mirror,
the black velvet backdrop,
the implied associations and traditions,
which the native illusionist,
the frack tales flying can magically use to transcend the heritage in his own
way.
Uh,
here being an exile prevents near Boca from making that night's move.
And you might think about that homophobic attitude to approve the in past the
fear that it's too,
like what he wants to do.
Uh,
but the main point here to think about is that that feeling of damage on the
other hand,
uh,
the critic Michael Wood has pointed out that in a book up didn't lose Russian.
You know,
he didn't lose it on the way while he was riding the boat.
He decided to stop writing in it and would says this new Boca could appreciate
language itself.
Only after he had made himself lose a language and have found another and the
ashes of his loss,
a kind of economy of a balance between the loss of one language and a particular
set of techniques that comes in it's place.
These techniques are really,
I think,
uh,
the source of the most appealing writing in this book.
Uh,
and so let's look now at one of those advocations of the American landscape,
which I just think maybe,
or the close of the book comes just a pure beauty.
Uh,
on page one 52,
oh,
and by the way,
this book was written on Road Trips,
uh,
in a book of his wife.
Vera drove him on thousands of miles of trips around the country while he was
writing this novel and hunting butterflies.
Think about that.
Um,
I'm a,
here's one 52 advocation of the landscape
by a paradox of pictorial thought.
The average Loland North American countryside had at first seemed to me
something I accepted with a shock of amused recognition because of those painted
oil clause,
which were imported from America in the old days to be hung above wash stands
and central European nurseries and which fascinated a drowsy child at bedtime
with the rustic glean views they depicted opaque curly trees,
a barn cattle Abrook,
the Dole White,
a vague orchards in bloom and perhaps a stone fence or hills of greenish garage.
So,
so far this is the American landscape is already a work of art already.
Part of a European memory,
then something else happens.
But gradually the models of those elementary rusticity,
he's became stranger and stranger to the eye.
The newer I came to know them beyond the tilde plain.
In other words,
they already worked over domesticated plane beyond the toy roofs.
There would be a slow,
so fusion of a new tile loveliness,
a low sun in a platinum Hayes with a warm field peach tinge pervading the upper
edge of a two dimensional dove gray cloud fusing with the distant amorous mist
and Utah loveliness.
That's kind of the keyword of new focus technique.
And he says the novel has as his only purpose to provide aesthetic bliss.
So here's the new tile loveliness coming just from seeing the landscape as a
stranger.
Humbert goes on.
There might be a line of space trees silhouetted against the horizon and hot
still Nunes above wilderness of clover and closed Loha clouds inscribed remotely
and to miss the Azure with only their cumulus part conspicuous against the
neutral.
Swoon have the background,
or again,
it might be a stern El Greco horizon pregnant with inky rain and a passing
glimpse of some mummy neck farmer and all around alternating strips of
quicksilver fish water and harsh green corn.
The whole arrangement opening like a fan somewhere in Kansas.
So European artists actually appears again there with closed though.
Huh.
But kind of made strange given that night's move,
given a new twist.
So instead of familiar incorporated into this profoundly strange,
vast landscape that gets a Humberto most appealing rhetoric,
the rhetoric of an exile.
But I don't want you to think that this just means everything's okay.
Of course everything is not okay.
Even Humbert will tell us.
So,
uh,
just a few pages later on page one 75,
he talks about his journey.
We had been everywhere.
We had really seen nothing.
And I catch myself thinking today that our long journey had only defiled with
the seniors trail of slime,
the lovely trustful,
dreamy,
enormous country that by then in retrospect was no more to us than a collection
of doggy of maps,
ruined tour books,
old tires,
and her sobs.
In the night,
every night,
every night.
The moment I feigned sleep,
you have to pair that with that other effication of the landscape to see this
alternate idea that actually this distanced criss crossing of the landscape
could be damaging.
I think of those other violent nights moves like,
like skipping past the mother's death.
Somehow this has skipped past that.
The hubs in the night,
there's a,
there's another version yet,
another version that relates back to that funny figure of gas don't go down.
Uh,
and I,
you know,
I spoke about Proust Gastro.
God has a picture of Proust on his wall.
In fact,
he has pictures of all great figures of French modernism on [inaudible],
the dancer Nijinsky or figures of this kind of aesthetic autism.
This belief in the power of art and all gag as go die himself is,
and Humbert has a kind of hatred for that.
Uh,
the sea which he voices on page one 73,
uh,
sorry,
one 83.
There he was devoid of any talent whatsoever.
A mediocre teacher of worthless scholar,
a Glum,
repulsive fat old invert,
highly contemptuous of the American way of life.
Triumphantly ignorant of the English language.
There he was in Priggish New England.
Here are we crooned over by the old and caressed by the young.
Oh,
having a grand time and fooling everybody.
And here was I
on the contrast here is between someone who has remained tied to that European
past,
remained constantly alienated and by that very means been able to fit into
society with someone who is in a much more ambivalent position.
Someone who's trying to become an American writer has an a book of says he's
doing,
trying to invent America,
uh,
trying to bridge the gap between a Russian and English,
but always finding that English is only a kind of second best.
Uh,
uh,
and he,
in fact,
it's more than that.
He translated Lolita back into Russian later on and he,
he added a second afterward
where he said this,
that wondrous Russian tongue that it seemed to me was waiting for me somewhere
was flowering like a faithful springtime behind a tightly locked gate whose key
I had held in safe keeping for so many years,
proved to be nonexistent and there's nothing behind the gate but charred stumps.
And to hopeless all tunnel distance.
And the key in my hand is more like a skeleton key.
So there's a kind of lost paradise of European culture,
which he can't get back even with this spectacular effort in English.
Uh,
so,
um,
that suggests that it's not all to the good.
It hasn't,
he hasn't been saved by taking up these nights move techniques,
the d familiarizing techniques,
there's still a record of damage.
And so,
um,
I just,
uh,
I'm going to end a little early just throwing out a,
an analogy for you and it's an analogy that,
um,
in a Boca of himself tries to debunk completely in that afterward.
So you should be skeptical of it,
but then you should also ask yourself whether you can really do completely
without it,
might it be that new Boca cuffs own relationship to American culture,
his relationship to the English language that he transforms is like Humberto
relationship to Lolita.
That is,
might it be that it's a kind of kidnapping of an American incent by a
cosmopolitan European for his own ends ends which are seen as a kind of
perversion.
Uh,
that's,
that's that element of violence that keeps coming back.
The trail of slime across this dream of transforming reality in this Joycey in
way into,
into something save that the dream of turning fate,
the fate of a dead mother or in focus own case of father killed by
assassination,
a brother killed in the concentration camps.
Turning that into this beautifully worked out playful system defined by Pons and
images and a spell of rhetoric.
In other words,
uh,
could it be that all of this,
modernist technique that Humbert succeeds in putting to his own ends,
that nimble cuffs succeeds and putting to his own ends is not an unambiguous
good but a record of a kind of damage.
Now,
on Monday you're going to hear about,
uh,
this novels confrontation with the idea that art could be saving,
that it could somehow be redemptive.
But here I think is,
I can't,
that it's something that the novel simply laughs at Holly Laughs at Holloway.
Uh,
and you might think of one last example.
There's all these things I've been saying about the delight and words is the
head mistress is put in the mouth of that horrible woman.
The headmistress of the Beardsley school,
Ms. Pratt on page one 97.
Okay.
Ms. Pratt says to Humbert,
I am always fascinated by the admirable way foreigners are,
at least naturalized.
Americans use our rich language.
In other words,
that the aesthetic discovery of English is something that just kind of fits
comfortably into this prejudice of the,
of the dull suburban American.
Um,
so I'll just end there with this,
with this thought,
this doubt about an a cuffs own use of modernist technique in this novel,
about the emphasis on the aesthetic here,
whether it could be not just that a triumph of the imagination that Humbert sees
in the list of names,
but a mark of a wound that can't be healed.